ah
i
y cubanos han salido a protestar en
washington en miami y en otras ciudades
de eeuu pidiendo la libertad para sus
compatriotas y más presión para el
régimen cubano el gobernador de la
florida de bonn de santis le pidió al
presidente by de que ofreciera internet
gratis a los cubanos pero bien reaccionó
diciendo que no está seguro si tiene la
tecnología para ofrecer esto el
presidente cubano miguel díaz canel ha
suspendido el servicio de internet para
evitar precisamente el crecimiento de
las protestas se insiste en que los
cortes de energía y la escasez de comida
se dan por el embargo económico y las
medidas de estados unidos contra la isla
al respecto fighter está considerando
permitir aumentar el límite de remesas a
cuba y enviar vacunas contra el cóver
por su parte el movimiento black light
matter emitió un comunicado pidiendo el
fin del embargo económico calificándolo
de cruel e inhumano comunicado que
generó muchas críticas por parte de los
republicanos
la grave situación que se vive estos
días en cuba disparó la confrontación
política aquí en españa en los partidos
de la derecha de la oposición no
tardaron en criticar al gobierno cubano
calificando de dictadura su régimen
mientras que en el seno del gobierno
español en coalición en las opiniones
son muy diversas por un lado tenemos a
la portavoz del partido de izquierda
unidas podemos quien dijo que para ella
cuba no es una dictadura mientras que el
presidente del gobierno español el
socialista pedro sánchez del afirmó en
una entrevista llega evidente que cuba
no es una democracia pero añadió el que
debía ser a la sociedad cubana quien
decida su camino sin injerencias la
derecha española
denuncia la tibieza del gobierno español
y mientras en las calles aquí pues la
opinión también está muy dividida entre
los que condenan el gobierno
y los que denuncian el bloqueo económico
[Música]
las históricas protestas
antigubernamentales en cuba el
presidente de venezuela nicolás maduro
ha ofrecido todo su apoyo al presidente
miguel díaz canel incluso a la
vicepresidenta del si rodríguez viajó el
viernes a la habana para expresar
solidaridad era de esperarse este apoyo
ya que cuba es uno de los aliados más
importantes de venezuela una relación
que comenzó con la llegada al poder de
hugo chávez que consideraba a fidel
castro- un padre político y también dado
a que ambos países comparten un enemigo
común
eeuu a quien responsabilizan
constantemente de conspirar para
derrotarlos y de sanciones y bloqueos
económicos de alianzas entre ambos
países e incluye el envío de misiones de
médicos profesores y entrenadores
recientemente venezuela también acordó
la compra de 2 millones de dosis de la
vacuna cubana a bala mientras tanto la
oposición venezolana liderada por juan
guaidó ha expresado su respaldo a los
manifestantes y ha acusado a maduro de
financiar la represión contra ellos
[Música]